[Music]
strength
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the break room everybody our
100th episode
the break room of course is the daily
that was a real bottle
from the avatar
i hope you had your glasses on uh this
is the daily nerdy news show that talks
about everything you need to know
live from the new rockstars headquarters
here in los angeles california we've
been doing this this is our 100th
episode i can't believe um and we're
going to have all kinds of wild fun
interesting uh celebrations of that
milestone later but 100 days of
celebrations i believe is what it calls
for that's right the next 100 episodes
we'll be celebrating the first one yes
that's right after after this
episode my body will be carried
90 miles
to pecoima oh no tommy will shed his
mortal feelings
he'll be they'll be doing the procession
twenty seven hundred miles to rochester
new york we'll all be laid down in front
of nick tahoe's and eaten alive by a
pack of street rats the sleeper has
awoken um but first we're gonna talk
about the news of the day uh including
today we're getting into a little bit of
uh she-hulk those um
uh sneaker easter eggs from the last
episode
we're gonna talk some scary movies
because it's scary movie season
uh we are actually gonna talk about
andor today confirmed promise we promise
we're going to get to some mandarin
discussion we're going to talk some loki
season two because you have some like
cool it's a little nugget of news that i
think we're going to blow out and make
really fun
and of course speaking of blowouts we're
going to get wild wet weird wacky for
our 100th episode
right
from our sippers
to our gifters oh i want to try to guess
every time
you've got to start pausing tommy when
you say from our blank to our blank uh
also uh we appreciate everybody we're
already uh seeing you in the chat thank
you to everybody that's saying happy
hundredth um and thank you brian k
already sending in his super chat thanks
for the 100th episode uh love there
brian um can you guys see our lower
halves
someone said uh dress dapper up top and
fun lower half oh well just just you
wait i am wearing sweatpants just you
wait till you see tommy's lower half
um i mean that all sentences are gonna
work and by the way you can check that
out on my instagram and my link tree
that'll be the old only fans folks it
dropped today and that's not the only
thing that dropped
my pants dropped
all right uh forever thanks for watching
mom we really appreciate you
thank you thank you thomas mom uh for
every hundred bucks we get in super
chats today we're gonna have a fun
redemption
um where
this is
um wild but we actually broke into our
own office
to steal some copy written songs that
were written for the break room yes so
now this is a snake eating its own tail
kind of situation we've we've broken
into warner brothers we've broken into
sony in the past we've broken into
disney
to steal songs written for our favorite
properties and then we sing those songs
for you on the show today we're singing
break room songs stolen from the break
room that's right
uh and if you die if this is your first
episode of the break room where have you
been yeah uh but if you don't remember
like this is something we do we've
stolen songs before we recently stole
some android songs yeah i think we have
a clip this is 100 episodes so we got
some clips this is uh like what this
situation is about previously before we
had stolen some more morbius songs i
think we have a clip of one of those
songs it's written by cardi b
it's written by cardi b
and they didn't put it in the normal
movie wow
are you allowed to say what the name is
it's called strong and bloody
okay
it's sob
certified creep
seven nights a week
strong and bloody milo wants a taste of
me
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah you messing with some dr morgan
bring your enemy in a vein for some dr
morbin bring your sister and a cane or
some doctor morbin that's
but we have other songs that we've
stolen from philip he keeps them in a
safe he's going to release now that's
what i call uh break room album yeah
we've stolen some of this song so every
hundred dollars in super chat the songs
that i took from philip's office are so
ridiculous and wild and i can't stress
enough that phillip wrote these
are all written by phil i actually found
a song i believe was meant for a
conceptual children's album
and then i and then i found another one
that i think was maybe written 40 years
ago oh very strange yeah way before our
new rockstar's ever existed um well
again hopefully we get to see a couple
of those if folks throw some doubloons
in the chat there but first we need to
get to some headlines
yeah
beautiful graphic um first and foremost
uh we all enjoyed uh a last week she
hulk b
jessica's breakdown of last week she
hulk c
we didn't get there's the first episode
we didn't get a post-credits scene i
believe right but we did get those those
nice like kind of courtroom illustration
style uh images spliced throughout and
one of um bug and what's her character's
name you say bug pug
okay all right i'm not the one breaking
it down
uh pagan nikki in front of a wall of
superhero themed sneakers right and
jessica did a great job of trying to
label what superhero went with every
sneaker uh very completionist there but
she-hulk director enu valia i think
that's how they pronounced their name i
hope um was asked about that and about
the lack of a post-credit scene in that
episode and she said in an interview
with tv line that i can't speak to that
all those easter eggs in that drawing a
lot of other minds had input there and i
did not so i can't really speak to that
um which is a uh
non-response
uh
but other minds that's interesting come
on the break room stop dodging i love
that we're just going to get these
people on the break room just to harass
them about their claims well seema lou
is going to pick up everyone on his way
to breakfast
[Music]
[Laughter]
ask your parents to rent it hey man
one of tom behringer is easily one of
tom barringer's business if you like
charlie sheen
pick another actor
whoa
tanisha massey come on
christian unpronounceable
mj2997 lots of folks coming through
generously uh so momentarily we're gonna
get one of those stolen songs like a
let's go buffalo in the super chats
buffalo dominant last night over the
tennessee titans let's just go a few
highlights of that no we have a package
i think different headlines those are
different headlines
uh real quick here i'm gonna read one
more headline then we're going to get
one of those uh stolen songs queued up
for you
kevin feige was surprised to hear that
director michael g aquino wanted to make
werewolf by night that's he's a longtime
composer of a lot of cool stuff
including a lot of marvel properties
who's the director of the werewolf by
night special presentation uh when he's
approached by feige to pitch a project
he wanted to work on michael was into
werewolf by night and fight feige's
response was really like really werewolf
wow okay
all right let's talk about it that's my
interpretation of how that response
might go that was a great read you're
hired that was that was spikey feeling
millions of dollars being sucked out of
his bank account
by night yeah someone can turn
you're a trusted creative within the
marvel universe and they're like pitch
of something right and your first thing
is like we're off by night yeah yeah
that is like but also it works he's
waiting to hear like actually he's
waiting why don't you go back to writing
songs trumpet boy
get the half out of my office that's my
fight uh speaking of writing songs um do
we have do we have one i mean we got one
of our signature artists mine are fine
but i'll i'll let one of our good
artists go
do you wanna join yours you want me to
do one um uh mine are pretty
oh yeah i can do one mine i can do them
all right i'm gonna do one of them
don't worry we're going to be singing
much more
this one is called um this is okay so it
says by philip molina
it says september 12
200
2018 so i think he was preparing oh he
was great wow just an idea four years
ago break room was just a twinkle in his
eyes which is interesting because the
title's called i won't say i'm trash wow
well i mean to be fair that that reads
for him
let's hope he can sing this yeah if
there's a prize for rotten trash heap
i guess y'all already done that
no host is worth the observation
that you're all trash bags you're filthy
trash bags you're a filthy trash bag
can't you see you smell so horrid you're
a walking red flag we're not live this
is pre-recorded you can't be reported
when you can't even think for your own
damn set health oh
no chance no way i won't say that i'm
trash you know it's right why deny it oh
it's too risque i won't say that i'm
trash
[Music]
there's a little bit more i don't know
oh beautiful that was wonderful not
accurate for our audience but wonderful
well our audience as you well know lives
in refuse they sleep in dumpsters they
don't just sleep there they live there
i see a lot of trash cans in the chat
thank you all uh to all the trash bags
watching all my trash bags all my bin
buddies we tried to call you breakers
and roomies but didn't you want every
trash bag didn't stick you know what
stuck
and and thank you to uh
suave elizabeth c gsu eagle you capreita
we're very close to a second song
already okay uh trust me these are worth
it let me uh let me squeeze in a couple
more headlines here uh we've got some
horror headlines which is wonderful as
we head into october horror uh
you got to check my only fans for the
other kind of things
fyi if you're if you're a horror fan not
only do we have some horror content
coming up very soon on the channel
jessica has a cool uh scary breakdown
coming out uh in the next week but we'll
be doing lots of horror stuff on the
break room in october yes spooky season
spooky season scary scary times scary
season scary season barbarian director
zach kreger uh was asked about potential
prequels and sequels to his hit horror
film barbarian the number one movie at
the box office two weeks ago big big
scary movie hit uh he was doing an
interview with the hollywood reporter
and he had kind of an interesting and
thoughtful answer where he was like yeah
if i did another movie in this franchise
it would have to tell the story of frank
which if you haven't seen the movie
that's a guy who kidnaps and assaults
women
and he was like basically i don't have
to hang out with that guy for an hour
and a half so he doesn't want to make
any more movies which i was like that's
a really thoughtful healthy response to
that also exit to you as you said from
the franchise yeah yeah now that you got
a little juice it's not stuck it takes
like 10 years to get this to screen so
it's like okay well and also i agree to
jump out of it but almost like 10 years
and his path is fascinating you know
he's on the whitest kids you know
sketch stuff forever i don't want to be
that person but let's not get too into
it because i break it down oh okay
that's the movie that jessica will be
breaking down soon yeah he has almost
it's funny how parallel his path is with
jordan peele right two people that
started in sketch comedy then
transitioned to making horror movies
right it's a very specific path
comedians can do anything because all
the rick and morty kids are
dominating everything all right straight
up all the rick and morty kids with
their pumped up kicks getting deals and
deals signed by kevin feige
okay okay this one this was also written
by phillip i think pretty recently crazy
he was pretty modeling recently i think
he was in his feelings he got this oh
boy this one this one is called well
that's not a hint that it's a drake song
because it's not a drink song this one
is called breaker one more time oh wow
okay
oh break up
how was i supposed to know
that it was 3 p.m
oh breaker breaker the super chats have
got to fly
to do this show again and show me
mandatory fun
and don't forget to smash that like
button
my trash bagness
when i'm not watching live i lose my
mind tune in on time
wow and if you don't get that i'm still
horny reference i think we got a
reminder
that we can play
my secret is
i'm always horny
[Laughter]
can you play one more time
my secret is
i'm always horny
[Laughter]
wearing the same pants in that shot and
that's why chad was going what about the
pants they can't tell if zach has pants
on oh they are flesh toned but they i am
winged unfortunately they're odd i was
gonna say there was a context for that
quote but maybe not uh maybe it's just
true universally thank you uh this is me
jessie waller match143 here for the
cookies lots of folks uh being very
generous in the super chat quentin um
carla ibarra we appreciate you um oh
speaking of got a little bit more scary
movie news um there was a uh hellraiser
trailer that just dropped they're doing
a full hellraiser reboot uh on hulu
absolutely which is like
uh know no i do not as a child
at the video store they used to they
used to rent out movies at a video store
the cover of a hell raiser yes yeah it
was too scary for me bears looking at
the cover the image of pinhead is
[Laughter]
doug bradley well in this new in the
reader
there's a young lady oh okay a young
lady
through her body and her body
oh yeah there will be all kinds of uh
strange s m scary type stuff the prequel
for willy wonka it's going to be a young
hell raiser yeah learning to put hooks
through his skin and well i read
interesting uh you know in the
the clive barker story that the entire
franchise was based on the pinhead
character was not gendered and was kind
of described with more feminine features
so maybe this is like a slightly more
accurate version and not just like
reboot it with ladies but also you can
reboot it with ladies it's still fun um
yeah i don't think we have this trailer
to play i don't think but uh
if you if you
if you're watching this not too late at
night or if you're not easily uh creeped
out watch that trailer it looks like fun
uh and then uh almost towards another
song already wow
wow
okay well let's i got one ready don't
worry tommy start doing your vocal
warm-ups
[Music]
well i don't think any of us could
either um uh speaking of uh horror movie
franchises uh we got confirmation from
director mike flanagan that a we're not
getting any more sequels or prequels to
dr sleep
that franchise has kind of been shelved
put on ice so to speak it has been put
to sleep i guess because didn't quite
make enough money at the box office when
dr sleep came out a few years ago um
tommy's getting texts from i'm not i've
launched the travis tommy's watching i
launched a translation heat on his phone
right now
the north hollywood shootout scene you
want to get all up in it uh okay well
tommy do you have a
do you have a song ready to go i do
i do this is so weird so
i found a box a cardboard box that was
full of like
whimsical costumes like whistles
like puppets and it said uh funtime
phillip and the friendship gang oh okay
and i think
what happened here is philip molino was
gonna leave new rock stars
and start like a like a children's show
he's coming for bluey yeah i love
playing he's coming for something but uh
so anyway this song is called if you're
happy hogan and you know it oh okay okay
and it goes a little
uh something i like this
you're happy hogan and you know it your
best friend died
if you're happy hogan and you know it
your girlfriend died
oh if you're happy
okay and you know it there's some stark
tech and you stole it if you're happy
hogan and you know it natalia died
natasha who's the dog oh yeah
i tell you it's a part of the [ __ ]
headlines
i'm starting the what headline
the horror
and i think it's a message about
grieving and loss yes thank you to
michelle scala mack lopez
player amy everybody throw it out chad
happy hogan is a tortured soul with a
tough life he is everything he loves
dies
uh he is at the nexus of a lot of
sadness um i know it's natasha you don't
have to call it a chat there's a there's
nothing natalia is that what uh uh was
that what a new mutant
yeah maybe i don't know yeah um okay uh
finally andor indoor news so andor is
dropping tonight we're gonna have a
little indoor chat later we're gonna do
some predictions for the season um and
uh the show runner tony gilroy talented
uh hollywood veteran screenwriter
director uh he did an interview with the
rap where he talked about me we already
knew that the show was already renewed
for a second season before the first one
even came out and he was like i've got
two more years to go uh i think it was
either brandon our time we were talking
about how dispirited he sounds in this
interview yeah yeah he was like uh
because he's the kind of guy's like i
don't think ahead on projects i do a
project and i finish it and then i worry
about the next thing and he was kind of
like by the time this is over i'll have
done 24 hours worth of star wars i think
i'm done and that's 24 hours of context
yeah right yeah 24 episodes
which is so many more episodes than
anything else there because originally
he he did rogue one and like they were
gonna do more movies kind of set in that
time space or based on that and then
obviously you know kathleen kennedy and
lucasfilm kind of changed they're like
ah no more movies yeah and he was done
and we talked about this before they
were gonna do this andor thing they sent
him the treatment and he was like this
is terrible and here's why and they were
like well why don't you come do it and
do it the way you like that's why a lot
of the reviews have been like this is
very different from all the other star
wars shows like this is his vision but
yeah this is kind of sad that like we
all thought he was working on part two
and like shooting at something yeah yeah
yeah but sounds like they're not going
to start shooting that until november
like yeah
david yashimoto yoshimoto uh so we're
probably not getting indoor season two
till 2024. we're guessing um fall 2024
yeah oh yeah late 2024 but there'll be a
lot of good other star wars content
between now and then um so you know and
hopefully the first season's so great it
keeps our bellies full of andorra first
but i think we should all be very
excited about andor folks and you know
what else i think we should be excited
about one thing i like to call
aspiration which is not just
a word it's a brand making small
decisions every day to help the planet
can have a big impact over time if you
keep your money in most standard bank
accounts they're lending your deposits
to fund out to fund oil and coal oil and
coal screw em switch to the planet side
and get aspiration aspiration is a
climate friendly alternative to big
banks get an account and a debit card
that's built to help your wallet and the
planet doesn't that sound nice yes
moving one thousand dollars to an
aspiration plus account has the same
impact is driving 6 000 miles less plus
you can earn up to 71 times as much
interest than at your old bank what
about ten dollars you know anything for
us aspiration is fossil fue
is fossil fuel free and lets you plant a
tree by rounding up every swipe of your
debit card now i like that that's
actually appealing to me aspirations
been hard at work helping people align
their money with their values funding
the planting of over 100
million trees try and count to that i
bet you can't on their way to funding
the planting of 1 billion trees 1
billion trees by 2030 no wonder why
forbes nerd wallet and the penny hoarder
recommend aspiration for the
eco-conscious we all want to do our part
to help the planet and you can make it
easier with a debit card from aspiration
best of all there's no credit check
thank god no overdraft fees and with
aspiration you just pay what you think
is fair even if that's zero because
money shouldn't stand in the way of you
doing the right thing make your dollars
make a difference open an aspiration
account at aspiration.com break room
debit
and move your money out of fossil fuels
i'm thinking about doing that today to
be honest
help save the planet with your
aspiration debit card open your account
at aspiration.com
break room debit today
aspiration.com
break room debit
terms and conditions apply now i do
believe thank you to uh some wonderful
folks including david yoshimoto uh
i think we got another song in the
hopper uh
brandon jessica your mother while
they're fighting over that just a
reminder you can always deposit your
money in my credit union
tommy's tanks
we put your money into old world war one
tanks and then we hide them deep in the
pacific ocean you want to pull your
money out you better be a good swimmer
and by the way every time you spend your
debit card i chop down 15 trees by
myself
i love i love uh world war one famous
for its pacific theater
no that's just where i dropped it
because i live in california there were
a couple guys out there duking it out
during world war one no one cared no i
can't it was me sloppy joe okay
you know frankie the fish again uh for
those folks just tuning in we stole
wow two songs thank you theodore harris
i was gonna do christian unpronounceable
your songs are always really good let me
do it no yours are really good you're
already i mean
actually that's actually our surprise
um uh you guys this is another song i
saw from fellow this was actually in his
um gym bag oh okay it's called thigh to
thigh oh my god i know what you're
thinking what does it have to do with
the break room in just your weight uh
tommy started singing it before we got
in here and i like tommy's version way
more than mine but uh maybe we'll get
ready to jump in
i got into the break room
the one i know you wish you were on a
doubles as the playroom
just make sure you don't touch my man
john maybe he'll uncover what he could
have seen all along
yeah
one way or another together we can both
get off if we listen to each other's
kinks john will never be my sneaky link
maybe
for the last time ever he's getting up
in my thigh whoa oh
my god
philip was walling out i think wow
philip has a thing for john phillip
john that's his sneaky link i'm gonna
need someone one of the cool teams in
the chat to explain that to me i don't
know what the hell any of that matters
wow
is it when i sneak sausages from my
breakfast
is that a sneaky link
those are my favorite sneaky legs
brandon while you uh warm up uh i just
want to talk real quick we got another
song on the way but i i want to quickly
uh talk about another sponsor we thank
aspiration for sponsoring the show
helping us bring uh our great sponsors
and i know um you know sometimes that's
maybe not your favorite part of the show
but it's all these great sponsors that
help us bring all these shows to you
it's an easy show to make and we really
appreciate everybody and if you can ever
click a link use our promo code anything
like that for a product you want to use
anyways that
is so helpful to keeping this show going
we really appreciate you out there but i
want to talk about you know that free
merch you get when you go to a
convention or a business meeting or
maybe you got to give me something for
free yeah the company you work for gives
everybody shirts or mugs or
hats or something like that you know
sometimes
those pieces of uh
swag are junk they're junk okay they're
not good stuff they fall apart they look
bad on you whatever
it's times like that when you really
want to promote your business
you don't give people junk you got to
turn to our friends at land's end okay
uh they make uh the best stuff thousands
of businesses have relied on lands and
business to outfit their employees and
promote their brand i personally i told
tommy this now this is a different
division of land's end but i had a lands
in rugby shirt or whatever style shirt i
got in seventh grade yep
it is still in my closet yeah now that
is both a reflection if i was an
extremely large 13 year old yeah okay
and i've not grown since i was 13.
that's right but also a reflection of
how strong and high quality their
products your arms and torso were set at
13. the rest of your body legs half the
length they are now i was just a shorter
version of myself yeah and i could yeah
let me probably tommy's mommy used to
dress him up it's um lane's end like a
little handsome lands end boy and every
now and then i sneak back into my closet
and i hike that lands enclosed back out
doesn't fit as well as zach's because i
kept growing exponentially like a
universe hopefully someday i'll begin to
contract but
the quality is unbelievable i had my
first kiss in my land's end vest wow and
i'll be buried in it
wow
promise uh they offer a timeless style
that fits every body type with the
widest range of sizes you'll find in
branded apparel you can have your logo
and vivid colors on shirts outerwear
hats mugs water bottles everybody loves
a vest yeah everybody loves a fleece
get your employees a fleece you know
what i mean be a character on succession
wear a fleece
that's a real flex the fleece flex
they've got all kinds of products
they're good for events holiday gifts
all that stuff
and they have a state-of-the-art design
and stitching technology to really
capture your specific logo and turn it
into a recognizable work of art they've
got great customer service email chat
phone support all that great stuff
whether you've got like 10 employees
about 25 like new rock stars or like 5
000 right they're great for it see why
thousands of companies count on lands
and business go to business.landzen.com
podcast
and use promo code podcast for twenty
five percent off twenty five percent off
is good
that's a quarter off i've heard
um that's business.com
dot sorry business.landsand.com
podcast promo code podcast for 25 off
yes the promo code is podcast
use it the link's in the description
right go for it because
uh okay i'll give you a song okay this
is actually this was a an andor song we
stole we were just oh right right right
uh apologies to andor uh this is one of
their songs we stole but it should be
shared with the world we hope it makes
it into one of the episodes this is
called me and cassia me and cassian down
by the schoolyard wow
here we go
okay sir a couple of rebels rolled out
of bed and they blew up the trooper
station
when the moth found out he began to
shout and he started the investigation
it was against the law
it was against the law
what my mother saw
it was against the law
saw guerrero looked down and spit on the
ground every time the empire's trucked
in
solid said oh if i get that boy i'm
gonna give him the board gullet suction
when i'm on my way
i'm gonna be a rebel i'm on my way i'm
taking an x-wing but i don't know where
goodbye to braya she's the queen of
alderaan she gets blown up hashtag
seeing me and cassian down by the
schoolyard
seeing me and cassie and down by the
schoolyard
well that's the end wow
but it looks like the one i got is from
a band called the freaky phils and the
midnight blasters
i need to know why your paper looks like
that
it was stolen i was stolen
it was
stored in a shoe yeah
it was stolen and i traveled many many
galaxies to get here um and now jessica
you you had a video you wanted to share
am i reading that right or or or i don't
know that it was you but we had we have
a video we wanted yeah it's pretty
obvious we haven't been referencing
someone lately yeah
they left us yeah it's our 100th episode
it's a big day for us but we want to
acknowledge someone who's not here with
us today right yeah so let's go ahead
and roll that video for that okay
[Music]
or we could
poor johnny you did this you people did
this to my baby boy john producer john
face
[Music]
athletic greens into a bottle and add in
a raw egg which have been sitting in
jessica's car
that's gonna be in me all right oh the
eggs last how'd the egg make it in the
powder part
wow
we're getting slack messages which means
it's probably philip yelling at us
you're the reason that we do this show
and you're the reason that i torture
myself oh god um
goodbye
[Music]
john uh not here physically with us in
spirit he's neither dead nor fired from
the show
okay yeah a lot of us so i think we
should just keep talking like you did
okay fair fair uh
uh yeah see so yes john you're out there
you somehow heard that song that i just
said
yeah john come sneak sausages off the
breakfast table with you guys
uh oh the grill's fired up and daddy's
cooking some links time to sneak them
out
oh my god
you guys now it's time for the moment
you've all been waiting for our
thumbnail we are talking about loki
season two because eugene cordero our
favorite comedian here in l.a up to a
series regular yeah
sorry tommy is
we got a pinned comment from john costa
in the chat john you're on vacation quit
watching the show yeah come on john
you're in a
sleep for the rest of your life vacation
eugene cameron up to a series regular
recently
my favorite comedian in la eugene
cordero sorry
i'm sorry
he's not going to come on the show with
this kind of people no eugene
come on the show and you can slap me
across the face i think you're great i
like that i do think you're great your
wife's very nice dude she taught me
level two at ucb let's go yeah eugene
was my coach for a minute he's great
joshua so uh season two of loki eugene
is going to be up to a series regular if
you don't remember who eugene is uh he's
the best character there he is right
there
casey
who said oh those are paperweights and
made me rethink the entire mcu as soon
as he said that so this season of loki
rumor has it will be getting more
background to the characters uh in the
story so we'll probably learn more about
casey before he was taken to the tva you
know how like ravona was uh turned out
to be like a school teacher it's like
we're going to start learning more about
these characters and maybe what they
have to do with season two and with the
timeline per se because maybe it's
something really big and maybe it's
something relatively small so we have a
series of characters that we're gonna
talk through and figure out what their
plans are in season two
sorry eugene cornell did play pill boy
in the good place which was
truly
truly incredible comedic performance uh
uh it's important to remember too that
when we were at d23 and we saw some of
the footage yeah we've seen this from uh
said photos that i've leaked if you if
you're into that kind of thing uh this
seems that they're really messing with
time in this one like we did see in like
season one how they went to the future
when like the hurricane was hitting the
rockstar facility and they went to the
80s to a medieval fair like it looks
like in this one they're really going to
be jumping around in time yeah and
giving uh these more side characters
like full episodes and like finding out
who their actual because they're all
variants right but who their real people
were maybe i think that's going to be
like important their real
who their real or their
their primary yeah
live on
uh dash will you bring them the first
one you can choose whichever one is your
first one because we'll talk about it
yeah so miss minutes oh okay miss
minutes because there was always that
theory lingering around season one of
who she actually is and what she was
before she was miss minutes do you guys
have any insight of what you guys would
theorize well i do love eric i think
eric did a video recently about the the
footage that was shown we kind of
speculated like is miss minutes gonna be
revealed to be the like
the real the real puppet master here
because like this is crazy like the only
character we've met that can hop from
like screens to off of screens and she's
definitely sentient in some way right
and is like has some interesting power
uh it'd be really interesting like yeah
is there a person voiced by um who's the
strong
do we see tara strong at some point oh
that would be fun if they just threw
terra strong yeah and somehow through
some weird process she becomes this kind
of like animated character like miss
minutes is a kang that was like
hiding in plain sight kind of someone
just said michael just said miss minutes
is ravonna oh okay
or or could it be
zola like the code the code got good
enough that it got into the tvs yes like
an ai
yeah yeah that's very good like that i
do like the um yeah is a ravona kind of
in the way of like loki gator is so
different from loki but what would be
insane is like that one is so big and so
bad that she can just jump timelines
like she can just even if it's on a
screen she just can show up in this
timeline the same as her actual other
counterpart like that'd be wild yeah
living in the same world uh so i would
love that for miss minutes we have
another one we have we have a lot so we
can keep going so this is the agent that
was that got hypnotized first and came
she was the first one to come too that
was like i don't know who i am or where
i am at last you saw me was in a bar and
now i'm working yeah she was at like a
tropical bar and we saw her and like
sylvia having drinks were like oh did
they know each other what is this and
then it was revealed that sylvia was
using her loki powers to get into her
memories oh yeah manipulating her to
learn stuff
uh which again is like a good clue and
i'm glad they're bringing that through
in a season too that like who these
people were is like very important
somehow and that's why we really need to
dive into it it'd be great to see her
come back
i don't remember do you think she could
come back because she's mad because
she's like she's like well
yeah yeah and b-15 who
the older version of b15 that we knew
before he who remained died she was in
on the cause mobius was in on the cause
they were all getting in on the cause
and then they kill her he remains and
loki comes back to a timeline that they
don't recognize him or everything's
different yeah i wonder if like loki's
gonna be trying to get back to
the original time space he was in season
one to get those versions of these
characters do you think that
because the way that it ended was him
being like
oh my friend and his friend being like
i'm not your friend i'm just the same
we're a co-worker yeah we're co-workers
and so do you think it's going to be him
just trying to get out of there and
people being like no you can't jump you
can't leave oh yeah like we're trying to
yeah this is where we stay
his brother was adopted thor was adopted
not kid loki so i'm i and it that
lingering on him was a little too long
of scenes where i'm like oh they're
going to bring him back i just don't
know when but is he one of those kids
that just lies about everything we had a
kid in my neighborhood he used to lie
like a rug was it you yeah
or it was me oh oh i'll never know
why i like the idea that the kid loki's
just a liar and it's just like i killed
my brother
what's his name richard grant is dead
right
he died fighting this yeah we see uh we
see him get consumed but they uh loki's
are so good at making it look like
they're right it's true you think he's
just like
yeah in theory they're all still there i
don't know what the destruction of the
timeline means for that space the void
if it becomes free if they get like
re-acclimated back to where they were
taken from i don't know
yeah maybe we learned more about the
void too right yeah i would love that
yeah because there is also still like uh
i think they called him boastful loki uh
the bald black guy yeah oh yeah he's
still kicking it yeah they're they're
all still yeah they're also president
yeah yeah loki gator yeah and even
president loki or whatever right he'll
be there
yeah great i love him give me my next
one hit me hit me two times okay
do we know her backstory no no and like
in that footage they show you do see her
uh it look like kind of like an old
hollywood there there's a set piece that
looks like they're at like an old
hollywood premiere maybe set in the 60s
or something like that this is in there
the d23 footage and this is kind of this
is sneak sneak peek they showed like
almost like a trailer yeah
ah sneak sneakers
brandon and tommy got to see stuff me
and tommy secretly with thousands of
other people
brandon and tommy down by the schoolyard
yeah oh
um i'll never tell you it looks like
there's some kind of major set piece at
this like old style highway premiere it
reminded me of like last night in soho
very much they're in tuxes and stuff and
15 is there and i'm wondering if this is
her story she was like some sort of
performer oh yeah interesting it got and
got plucked or is this present hunter
b-15 getting sent undercover or
something like that right do they take
did he who remains or kang who whomever
take those people who are wise to the
game and send them back to where they
were
to kind of get them out yeah because we
haven't seen her right we only saw at
the end at the end she was like out she
we saw her
kind we saw at the very end she was
there with mobius but those were
different versions of them oh that's
true yes
but she was wise to it she had gone to
ravona school and stuff like that she
was like
hyped to what was happening reminder
when are we getting loki season two next
year this is right this next summer 2023
okay
2028.
that is false tommy um
maybe like about the same time we got
moon night this year then maybe maybe a
little later maybe more like miss marvel
oh right right okay great summer i think
there is one more is there one more
daschle
there it is
mr jetski himself all we know is that he
likes to jet ski that is literally all
we know what if he's just like a serial
killer that likes the jet ski i don't
think he is but i'm just saying we all
you think he's the jet ski killer
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what if he is a jet ski
oh
i like that existence is
[Music]
paint what does wait no what does a luke
wilson jet ski sound like wow
wow
[Music]
now what does an owen wilson jet ski
sound like oh wow
[Music]
sorry bubba the thickest dog in the
world just walked into this that's a
sneaky link that's not you don't know
what sneaky link is
am i bae or am i just a simp you're
being you're being is this choogie
zack is a losing you are killing zach i
know all the hip lingo you clearly do
not am i daddy oh my gosh you're making
me upset
that's mid
um i think that was actually is that
that was last one right i think that was
it yeah
those are our major well i mean we are i
i would say of all this series and this
is again the first second season of a
marvel disney play show forget it right
so it's like
uh some storytelling possibilities that
we haven't yet been able to explore
we're very excited for it well and it
did seem like they pulled the trigger
pretty quick on loki's season two after
the success of season one but maybe that
wasn't always the plan i don't know
if at some point they decided like oh
this is working this is where we want to
go and this plays into some long-term
storytelling goals right like we know
kang is a big part of the future of the
film uh mcu and like obviously he's
gonna be a part of loki so like clearly
loki season two is gonna be woven into
this kang dynasty kind of uh
storytelling yeah great um tommy
it wouldn't be a 100th episode if it
didn't have
this segment ain't mid
i'm gonna it's time for
mandatory five
look at that
the segment
so enjoyable
we make the graphic deployable
hit it again
i had to do the graphic yesterday and i
did a really bad job you did a great job
i'm sure
the segment that is so
well demanded that we keep the graphic
on hand and hit it again
yeah yeah
are we gonna do a hundred graphics for
everything right i mean i can't say that
one the segment that has caught the
world by storm so we make playing the
graphic the norm hit it again
look at that wow now
it's our hundredth episode
and you know what that means
it's time for some toasts guys
we made a wheel of toast we're all going
to deliver toast based on the wheelies
but we have a very
very
we've got a very special guest
in the house
[Applause]
our producer dodson has flown all the
way from nebraska oh no just kidding
from texas
to join us at the toast come on in
john died of consumption but producer
yeah
look at him
he's here we get a datsun signing all
right
so a dodge since a wild dog we're all
going to spin the wheel of toast who
wants to go and to be clear tell me what
is on the wheel let's see we've got
things like
oh can we get our toasty things we've
got a butter toast
a french toast a best man toast a
toasted toast
host toast
the off the screen producer toast a mom
toast which i think is like pronounced
you're behaving like a mom a toast to mt
a toast to jack nicholson
a boast toast
a toast to whomever texted you last
and one i can't read i think it says a
toast to philip a toast of philip well
we'll skip that one
we've also got our mandatory drink and
by mandatory i mean it's not alcoholic
yes you can have the red or the white
hopefully by the 500th episode we'll be
drinking straight champagne homies
we have to wait that long or gain
champagne who cares
because he said straight champagne first
uh
yeah or unidentified champagne
um california sparkling as it were
okay well tommy should you lead us off
and again the general premise here is
we're thrilled to be at 100 episodes
we're so appreciative of everybody to
help make it happen that we're going to
toast to the success of the show right
yes we're going to toast i believe there
is yeah you can toast the chat god i
hope i don't get that one i can't say
nice things about them i'll spin the
wheel first
nice spin
the wheel sounds like it needs some
maintenance
oh i missed it i missed the australian
toast
toast to whomever texted you last okay
is it one of us
all right
this is a toast
to my friend garrett kirby oh i love
garrett
garrett do i have a do i have a juice oh
i am important i don't know
you know what this is actually good guys
i'm glad i'm gonna make a toast to my
friend gary kirby
because
garrett kirby has watched the break room
before oh what a guy garrett kirby
unlike all of you is not trash
in fact garrett kirby
often calls people trash along with me
we are what we call
each other the garbage pails
because we identify trash i'm noticing a
theme garrett's wife darlene wants super
chat at 20
oh
i you know not that i keep tabs on what
my friend super chip but i don't have a
lot of other friends that have ever
super shattered
so here's to garrett here's the darlene
for being what i call the super chatters
you know what i mean out of the trash
into the high life away from the dirty
dirty regular chatters that live in
their garbage dumps have miserable lives
broken marriages children of divorce
[Music]
to garrett and darlene
oh yeah yeah
feel free to drink along with us at home
i want to quickly shout out stacy c eva
linda clayton cayton uh i think here for
the cookies had another chat in there
thank you all
brandon's spinning the toast wheel
jack nicholson oh
my boy jack or or in the style of jack
nicholson if you can pull off either way
hey
hey everyone out i yell you trash bags
you're living great you're having a
great time
you're living good uh don't you want to
watch the game huh raise your hand if
you want to watch the game you guys see
one flew over a cuckoo's nest you guys
see wolf i was in that one running
through the woods eating a deer hey
whatever you do wear your sunglasses
because you're high as hell wherever
you're going and let's hear it for the
lakers baby
let's do it lakers i don't know a single
laker let's do it
do you ever wonder where we got all
these wonderful toys hey you gotta tell
me
where did they get all these wonderful
toys
he's at home washing his tights
[Applause]
jack nicholson jack nicholson
jessica
there you go
thank you to paula a in the chat thank
you thank you thank you good chat
have a lot of clayton in the chat please
no accent
toast whatever that means to you
i put this for everybody else to do but
give us a butter toast a butter toast um
i feel like butter's smooth as hell oh
yeah oh okay i want to give them smooth
like butter
i want to give a toast oh to all you
lovely people in the chat oh very good
all of you that show up every day and
some of you that tuned in today
maybe you saw our tick tock maybe you
saw her post on twitter and you said hmm
those are four fine ass individuals oh
my god i'm getting a sneaky one so that
you don't know what a sneaky link is you
can at me if you want me to be somebody
sneaky
what kind of sausage do you like
what what's your favorite type of meat
oh
i'll serve it up to you wrong oh my gosh
it's a raw sausage
damn after awesome
wow
okay that was excellent let's see
let's see how i can follow that oh i
don't even know if i got a full uh round
a toast to mt okay all right and i'm
gonna take this opportunity mt um one of
the uh few people at new rockstars that
has not been on uh an episode of the
break room though we'd love to get him
on here one day and i quickly before i
toast to mt i want to talk to everybody
that's appeared on the break room and
we've had
a lot of special guests or recurring
guests i'm talking about your erica woo
sues your tom michaelson's your angelica
treys your whitney van laningham your
phillip molina's eric voss on at least
one occasion
um two occasions uh
on the show anna anna vanson yes
wonderful and probably a couple john
michaelson did he i did mention tom hank
hank the dog
sam for doing all the drawings yes and
that i wanted to do a quick shout out to
the folks behind the scenes that help us
make this show uh samantha who works in
the office almost any time you see art
on this show especially anything that's
drawn on a whiteboard samantha does an
awesome job at that and is super helpful
in a lot of ways behind the scenes and
then other folks that work in rockstars
like patty and riley and phillip and
lots of other folks help us out in a ton
of ways we really appreciate all of them
and then i want to shout out the mods
who um are doing the lord's work in the
chat i'm talking about chrissy mezzo
uh fray girl there's probably a couple
other mods i'm forgetting
thank you coy people are wanting us to
shut up oh and i forgot to mention coins
super special guests
and you can tell him i said that that's
this is correct replacement okay wow uh
okay well uh my yeah uh the partial
toast to koi who who i'm cool with but
apparently has done something to wrong
jessica but uh
we appreciate all of you we appreciate
everybody that's always in the chat uh
somebody jordan tauren just said been
watching you guys from the beginning we
really appreciate that i think one thing
we've discovered here on the show is the
fun community that this show has built
yes the dumb jokes the um the ponies in
the chat the only ponies in the chat the
bony ponies in the chat all the things
that we punish the mods by having to
filter out all the awful things that we
ask the chat to say all the time we
appreciate all of you and so um thank
you for making this a weird uh fun
little experiment so successful and
to our brother-in-arms mt uh we love you
uh you are a nerd the nerd daddy to all
of our nerd babies
and uh we'd love to get you on the show
sometime very soon uh thank you for
everything you do mt
don't let the joy and all your trash
back don't let the door hit you where
the good lord splits you yeah okay
when you're tucking yourselves in your
bins do you want to do a speech yes
let's do it
and then also
spin the wheel i love spinning the spool
anyways this is somehow less sweet than
actual champagne it's not over yet
spread it i'll spin it again
another toast to empty he's had his
flowers
someone rigged the wheel in australia
you could do an australian accent or you
can toast the good people of australia
forced to watch the show upside down you
know you're about to hear me
in that australian you better do this
toast backwards
oh yeah or upside down yeah um whoo okay
australian crocodile thunder okay okay
crikey right oh i can't tell you how
appreciative i am of all you people in
the chat here every single day
just giving all your your money and and
super chats and your polls and
everything here i don't appreciate all
the weird comments that i have to block
some of you
need therapy just gonna say that right
there um that's fine
yeah thank you thank you to all of our
i've been losing it now
cronky thank you to all of our mods just
we already really talked about them
earlier before but i wanted to make sure
that i shadowed them out right here
before uh mezzo cody all of you guys
there and um
thank you for tuning in to the break
room every day
nor why what a tire
[Music]
jealous don't feel tommy can barely
also yeah for the folks that noticed
tommy is wearing a buffalo bill zubaz
yeah that is correct uh he didn't put
them on when the bills won last night
his body instantly creates them yes
these are just my legs like a cocoon
he's he's like a buffalo bill satter he
uh uh he's he's bills from the from the
waist down that's right well doctor we
thank you as well we cheers to you
thank you for everything you do thanks
guys
we've got
just a bit more time left
we should we do want to make some indoor
predictions but we're going to do things
a little differently this year
this year this season i have seen andor
oh when they get the dice not all of it
but i have seen a few episodes so it
wouldn't be fair for me to make
predictions as i
you know presumably should know what's
on the show now i have no short-term
memory due to years of helmet-to-helmet
hits on the football field so you know
once a once in a while i can i can draw
a memory but how we're gonna do it this
year is you guys are gonna draft a
character okay from an episode or in
this case three episodes
and uh
the first three episodes which premiere
tonight and then i'm gonna have a scale
i have a i have a system that is like
this is based on
uh do they do something noble do they do
something treacherous do they actually
kill someone do they kiss someone do
they say something star wars-y
all of those things your character will
get a score by me revealed tomorrow on
the show after the episodes so
i've got four characters from the first
three episodes for you guys to draft
from i've got cassie nandor himself i've
got bix the frisky junkyard owner with a
secret pest
i've got uh cyril karn
the police officer private security
officer who's just trying to make his
way up the ranks but maybe he's a little
too overzealous and then i've got marva
andor who is uh played by the lovely
fiona shaw look for my interview with
her coming out sometime on this channel
uh
uh that is uh is kind of the motherly
figure to the people of this area is
this related to cassian yes am i taking
that by her last name she's a surrogate
mother figure okay so now uh roll the
dice to see who gets the giraffe first
and again tommy has seen these episodes
none of us have yeah so we are both
trying to draft these characters based
on what our guest oh a four from brandon
okay that's a six-sided dice and he's
already got a four okay
jessica's got a five okay
you got it all set now looking good
looking good for me uh
booty beads here we go and four
all right we gotta get a re-roll okay
brandon and i for second place here
four all right
jessica brandon zach jessica who would
you like to draft first i choose one of
the characters oh my god i just spent 10
minutes explaining them
i'm just kidding yes
i like the junkyard person all right you
get bicks good good pick all right i
mean i gotta go cassie and andor his
name's in the title
all right okay i'm gonna go i would have
gone i would have gone and or i would
have gone cassie myself too but you know
what love fiona shaw talented actress
uh apparently tommy really had some
chemistry with her in their interview
palpable they might be meeting up in
person we don't know so i'm going to go
marva i like that all right cyril car
and suck it now i'll take karen as my i
will i'll be playing as the house no
card will be my character okay and
you're gonna do this every week where
you're going to take the one under the
one that does not get picked okay and
that'll be mine now
before
huh did you get a good pick oh yeah
uh i got some sneaky links
before this is how we're going to finish
this off you guys are each going to give
me a line of dialogue from the character
and if that line
is is even remotely said
in the in their episodes you will get
some bonus points so give me a bix line
jessica um he's a junkyard person she is
a junkyard she's a junkyard person yeah
um
no not that droid okay okay nice okay
okay
and i thought the empire was bad great
that's what andrew's gonna say i like
that okay and then i'm gonna say marva's
gonna go
that ain't no moon whoa
i should have gone i
love it now and we do know we do know we
have a
up the she-hulk fantasy scores yeah
we'll do that tomorrow tomorrow
we'll be getting our predictions there's
a lot of fantasy going on right now a
lot of predictions that got to be made
don't you worry we'll shore all that up
tomorrow yeah for sure now we'll get it
clear we're all
we're about wrapping up now yeah we've
got a few more songs yeah i want to
shout out trash bag i appreciate you
trash bag because you changed your uh
youtube screen name to trash bag bear
trap one two four nimbus galleon
ein kolkahan you have a beautiful name i
have no idea how to pronounce it ein but
that's my best attempt uh thank you to
everybody that's been super chatting
today uh tommy there's a a song that
needs to be heard yeah i think there's a
few but i mean i'll sing mine really one
this was again this was i found this in
a box labeled freaky fill up in the
midnight thrusters okay wait one more
time freaky phillip in the midnight
thrusters
okay
wow thrust
there used to be a shulker break room
that streamed at three
you
became the trash bags that disgusted me
fun
remains
the segment that's
mandatory
but did you know that when they go what
i set up my bed
sometimes i hear a guy breaking in and
say hey hey
now that you know
where i snooze
i have nothing to lose can i keep all
the super chats
wow
and that was my freaky philippines the
midnight thrusters
yeah i think that's this is
this is our 100th show yeah we should we
should take a quick look you might not
know maybe you just joined today maybe
you came in around show 69 yes hey yo
but maybe you wonder how it all began
and you could easily look on youtube but
you haven't yeah because the playlist is
long at this point let's show you a
little clip of how this show began from
our very first show where we went live
oh no i gotta sing a little song like
there might not be music but there are
music
or so i've been told we never hello and
welcome back to the break room or maybe
welcome to the break room for the first
time this is a new show we're doing here
daily on new rock stars right here on
the youtube channel we're going to keep
you updated about what's going on in
nerd news from our very own break room
yes we are live coming to you from our
break room do we just twist it
oh
hey
okay
the way our system is oh
oh no
look at that
look how far we've come it's got
habaneros
the decoration on the cake is little
peppers in honor of all the times we've
debased our own mouths
by eating spicy things
and then we've got uh some champagne
some really powerful champagne poppers
that we'll be exploring exploded in a
moment you guys know i love these things
again uh we've got big big plans for the
next hundred episodes of break room it's
if you like it already it's gonna get
better if you hate it already well it'll
get better
and by the way if you hate it keep
watching because you're obsessed with it
i know also if you made it into 62
minutes of the show and you hate the
show hey i guess thanks
hit like hit like on this uh video if
you haven't already subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already on this
video uh we'd actually appreciate it uh
with that said um we're gonna give it
more depth what should our final uh
salute here be uh
uh i think harry oldman right
oh and you have the same gary i think on
the count of three
uh gary oldman to take us out
well uh does anybody remember the latest
no i think just one hit gary okay we'll
just shout gary oldman on three okay
thank you everybody thank you one two
three gary
here we
i'm just go
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
you